[Music]  I have to sing I have to play the music  it's it's not just in me it is me when  life gets me down I play my guitar the  rest of the world may follow the rules  but I must follow my heart do you know  that feeling like there's a song in the  air and it's playing just for you  [Music]  never underestimate the power of music  no one was going to hand me my future it  was up to me to reach for my dream grab  it tight and make it come true  [Applause]  all right losing them  [Music]  [Music]  you guys stay with me boy know where we  are  [Music]  this she's gonna choose em you're all  really out there  [Music]  I've missed what are you doing since you  don't have a job I just wanted to help  ah excuse me